Captain America hand over your double
silver bar insignia I am busting you
down to the rank of second lieutenant
America because your shield is so
metallurgically moronic if there's one
thing I hate about Earth 199.99 the
version of the earth where the Marvel
Cinematic Universe takes place it's the
fact that they've altered the
ingredients in Captain America's giant
fling oval disk of decency and know-how
winghead ricochets his shield around
newsflash
those ricochets are physically
impossible and not just because those
shots are impossible even for a computer
no it's simple material science and
basic physics based on what the shield
is supposedly made of for the longest
time the comic book version of the
shield was an alloy that combined
indestructible adamantium with vibranium
a substance that can absorb all kinetic
energy but in an egregious departure
from the official Marvel handbook the
new movie version of the shield is all
vibrating tomato vibranium it's
completely vibration absorbent by the
hoary hosts of fargöth why did Fox lock
up the rights to adamantium along with
the x-men franchise let me break it down
for you and Super Hero Squad simple
terms if it really was such a thing as
energy absorbing vibranium and if
Captain America's shield was actually
made from it that shield would not
rebound like a billiard ball off of a
bumper the vibranium would absorb the
kinetic energy of the collision
rendering it totally inelastic it were
dropped like a dead tennis ball hitting
it
no way could an all vibranium shield
perform endless bad-guy bopping bank
shots spread the word and demand a fix
maybe a timely read Kahn it explains
this unforgivable error can still be
snuck into Avengers 2 age of Ultron the
Captain America beat the Hulk in
Ultimate Frisbee let me know in the
comments